conséquence de la crise sanitaire les
intermittents du spectacle reste
mobilisée pour certains afin de réclamer
une deuxième année blanche en raison de
cette crise sanitaire ils demandent le
retrait aussi de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui entre en vigueur
en juillet on va en parler tout de suite
avec notre reporter bat sam shemie
[Musique]
bonjour vasselle après avoir occupé
l'aude et on s'en souvient les
intermittents du spectacle ont investi
pendant quelques heures un autre lieu
culturel qui est également un centre de
vaccination
bonjour magali effectivement une
occupation qui avait fait beaucoup de
bruit
souvenez vous c'était depuis le 4 mars
et intermittents du spectacle occupait
le théâtre de l'odéon beaucoup de
banderoles avaient été dispatchés sur la
façade pour alerter le gouvernement et
puis ils ont fini repas ils ont fini par
partir par eux mêmes à partir de 6
heures du matin c'était hier laissant
une seule banderole on pouvait lire au
revoir un message clair adressé et à la
direction et au gouvernement
il avait déclaré par la voix du
secrétaire général cgt spectacle les
négociations et le climat devenait tendu
avec la direction impossible de
communiquer ils ont donc quitter l'odéon
pour venir ici au 104 un théâtre
mythique de la capitale
ils sont arrivés hier quelques tensions
avec notamment les forces de l'ordre et
la sécurité
d'après le syndicat cgt et spectacles
des discussions sont en cours avec la
direction de ce théâtre là ils ont même
a déclaré ne pas rester sur place ils
sont rentrés chez eux mais vire
viendrait aujourd'hui à partir de 14h
pour une assemblée générale
un mouvement de protestation et surtout
des blocages de théâtre ça effet à un
effet de boule de neige plus d'une
centaine de théâtre à travers la france
sont concernés par ces blocages
ils sont bien déterminés à se faire
entendre par le gouvernement pour qu'ils
puissent prendre leurs revendications au
sérieux face à cette crise du coa
navires us et basse année
revendications restent tels les mêmes
effectivement les revendications restent
les mêmes principalement c'était sur
leur situation face à la crise du
coronavirus emmanuel macron avait
déclaré une année blanche pour les
intermittents du spectacle et
techniciens l'année blanche qui doit se
terminer dans quelques mois
hors de question pour ces intermittents
et demande une seconde année blanche car
cette année a été pour catastrophique
dur à surmonter et même si les théâtre
rouvre progressivement ils ont dénoncé
une réouverture de deux poids deux
mesures c'est pas suffisant pour eux
certains spectacles ne pourront pas
reprendre les programmations ralenti
modifier une activité qui pourra pas
reprendre normalement ils demandent
également le retrait de la réforme
assurance chômage et qui doit arriver à
partir du mois de juillet des
revendications qui ne semble pas être
entendu parler au gouvernement le
gouvernement qui a déclaré qu'il était
en état c'est qu'il fallait absolument
que ces mouvements 16 pour que la
programmation culturelle puis se
reprendre sans pour un message adressé
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux par la
ministre de la culture roselyne bachelot
je vous propose d'écouter
nous avons entendu et répondu aux
demandes de ceux qui occupent encore un
peu plus de 60 théâtre le moment est
venu d'arrêter les blocages de permettre
au public de revenir en sécurité dans
les salles de laisser artistes et
techniciens travailler et vivre la
culture ensemble le message du
gouvernement est claire ils peuvent
continuer à revendiquer certaines choses
continuer à manifester mais il ne faut
absolument pas gêner la réouverture des
tâches vous rappelle que le théâtre de
l'odéon devait elle rouvrir le 19 mai
l'ouverture qui a été impossible aux
yeux du blocage de ce théâtre il faut
savoir aussi que le statut des
intermittents du spectacle et
techniciens est une spécificité
française ils peuvent en et bill
bénéficier à partir de 507 heures les 12
derniers mois un statut assez
particulier que les intermittents du
spectacle souhaiterait revoir avec le
gouvernement il concerne pas moins de
120 mille personnes artisans artistes et
puis technicien une problématique pour
ces techniciens essaient d'artistes ils
demandent au gouvernement
reconsidérer leur statut notamment un
statut qui a été lourdement affectée
avec cette crise du cornât des russes
ils ont déclaré en arrivant ici au
théâtre du centquatre qu'ils
continueront ils ne lâcheront pas les
mouvements vont s'intensifier je sais
que le gouvernement puisse répondre
favorablement à l'ensemble de leurs
revendications
merci beaucoup vincennes pour ce point
très complet sur la situation des
intermittents qui font le siège à paris
toujours pour obtenir davantage de
subventions